- I just met the Yodeling Kid.
- Oh my god,
I'm about to meet the Yodeling Kid.
Hello everyone, Ivan here,
and I am at the 2018
Radio Disney Music Awards
asking celebs to build
their dream Disney squad.
Let's go!
Who would you pick as your Disney squad?
If you have to pick like three
or four Disney characters
from your favorite movies
and a place you would take them.
- Probably Rapunzel from Tangled,
that'd be a first.
- Simba, young Simba, definitely.
- And where would you take them?
- We goin' on vacation.
- Where?
- Where are we going?
Where are we going?
- Uh...
- Atlantis!
- The High School Musical squad.
- Okay--
- And I'd take 'em back
to East High School and be like,
"Yo, film High School Musical 4."
- I'm signing that petition.
- Maybe Belle from Beauty and the--
I mean, I dunno,
that's my favorite movie,
I still got the biggest
crush on her, so...
- Take her out to dinner.
- You would take her on a date, more like.
- Uh...
I would take her more than just a date.
I would literally (record scratching).
I'd take her to the beach or something,
I dunno.
- Oh, okay,
I didn't know where that
was going for a second.
- Phineas and Ferb.
I wanna have a good summer this summer,
so Phineas and Ferb
I feel like they would help me.
- I would choose
Shia LaBeouf in Holes.
I would choose Jett Jackson.
- Ohh.
- I love him.
I love him, I miss him, I love him.
I would choose Jett Jackson
and I would choose the
guy from the Jersey, too.
(laughs)
- Ooh!
- But that's because I
grew up with all of them.
And I want Nick Spano
'cause you love me and I love you.
Okay, cool.
- Maybe Mal from Descendants.
- Just Mal?
That would be it?
- I think Mal because, you know,
she got the eyes and she
can turn into a dragon.
A dragon.
- But that to me sounds
more like a date with Mal
than just hanging out
with a squad. (laughs)
- I'd have the emperor
from Emperor's New Groove.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that guy.
- And I'd have the dude
that is his friend.
- The big guy?
- The big guy, I'll be him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I gotta go with Hercules...
- Okay, cool.
- Hades...
- Okay.
- Donald Duck,
and my girlfriend Maya.
- Amazing combination.
All right, and where would
you take all of them?
- Where would I take them?
- Yeah.
- Probably Disney World.
Or Disney Land.
- You're a big fan?
- Of course.
- Me, too!
- Yeah.
We should go together!
- Can I join?
- I'd love that!
Only if you wear that shirt, though.
- I would wear this shirt for you any day.
So I'm here with Mason Ramsey,
I just met him,
I'm super excited.
We're trying to find out
who would you pick as your Disney squad?
If you have to pick like two
or three Disney characters
that you really like.
- Uh...
- Is there any Disney movie that you like?
- Yeah?
When I was three
(children yelling)
I'll just flat-out tell
you the truth, all right?
- Okay, tell me the truth.
- So when I go home,
I'm not allowed to watch TV.
- If you have a squad,
where would you take your squad?
Go home and chill?
- And play video games.
- Oh!
- Mulan.
- Oh, Mulan, easily.
- Original feminist icon.
Hello.
- Captain Jack, I guess?
- Okay.
- Jack Sparrow, I like that.
Jack Sparrow's Disney.
- And Ariel.
- Kim Possible.
Love Kim Possible.
Raven-Symone, who I work with,
but she'd be amazing in a Disney squad.
- She's already a squad, I feel like.
- We already form our own squad
within our cast, so yeah.
But that's a ideal Disney
squad, if you will.
(upbeat horn music)